je suis une mauvaise actrice toi une
mauvaise avocate nous devons s'employer
demain nous serons à la rue sûrement une
bonne nouvelle inspecteur de la sûreté
vous aviez bien rendez-vous chez
Monsieur Montferrand je suis Montferrand
et mort il a été assassiné
Hélène des événements les plus heureux
de ma vie
[Musique]
et elle aurait 50 prisons pas forcément
légitime défense alors c'est moi
vous avouez je suis le plus heureux des
hommes moi aussi enfin des femmes
depuis quelques années les femmes nous
suppriment avec un sansogènes
en 1935 de mener sa carrière sa vie de
femme en toute égalité
différente à présent
décidément ton crime fait des miracles
[Musique]
je crois que mon prix est en train de
tourner la tête de toutes les femmes
bonjour mes poupées mais regardez-moi ce
lu c'est robe de chambre
[Musique]
les coupables qui nissaient ennuyeux
mais les innocents qui s'accusent c'est
exaspérant
[Musique]